and the Oscar goes to Lady gaga it was a
big night for Lady gaga
at the 2019 Academy Awards on Sunday
night taking home an Oscar for shell oh
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much to the Academy for
this wonderful honor thank you to every
single person in this room thank you to
Mark Ronson - Anthony Russell and OH -
Andrew Y at my co-writers I love them so
much - my sister my soulmate I love you
my family's here I love you mom and dad
Bradley there is not a single person on
the planet that could have sang this
song with me but you thank you for
believing in us thank you so much it's
not about winning but what it's about is
not giving up if you have a dream fight
for it there's a discipline for passion
and it's not about how many times you
get rejected or but you fall down or
you're beaten up it's about how many
times you stand up and are brave and you
keep on going thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
gaagaa stunned in 120 8.54 karat Tiffany
necklace the diamond has been worn only
three times in history and was last worn
by audrey hepburn in 1961 are you ready
for this performance oh oh yes we are
ready and so excited so excited how does
that feel to know that you could walk
away tonight being an Oscar winner you
know I I haven't I haven't really been
able to fully process that you know it's
one of those things you just never know
what's going to happen and the truth is
I'm just happy to be here in the
presence of such incredible artists I
mean so much talent in this room and
it's been my dream since I was a little
girl that I would be able to even you
know work as an actress to work as a
musician to make it in this world and I
just I can't believe that I'm here and
I'm so very happy and my whole family is
here with me is everybody yeah they are
not that nervous about tonight he's calm
cool I collect everybody saying oh yeah
he's you bradley's chilla but perhaps
Gaga's biggest moment of the night
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the crowd was astonished backstage in
the lounge during Bradlee and Gaga's
electrifying performance
we caught Gaga passing through Bobby
what and to get this during a commercial
break
Bradley and Gaga received a standing
ovation as they return to their seats I
wish that you all could have witnessed
watching him sing take after take life
this was sung live every single time
what you see in this film was son live
it was recorded live it was recorded
live properly so that it was sound
fantastic and he also directed at the
same time and I I truly hope that
everyone in the room tonight when they
saw our performance saw the true
brilliant man that he is the actor the
director the screenplay writer the
producer the musician
[Music]